good afternoon I want to begin by
answering the big question that people
have been asking in the last 48 hours
and that is is this government asking
you the people the public to do one
thing while senior people here in
government do something else have we
been asking you to make sacrifices to
obey social distancing stay at home
while some people have been basically
floating those rules and endangering
lives and it's because I take this
matter so seriously and frankly it is so
serious that I can tell you today I've
had extensive face-to-face conversations
with Dominic Cummings and I've concluded
that in traveling to find the right kind
of childcare at the moment when both he
and his wife were about to be
incapacitated by coronavirus and when he
had no alternative I think he followed
the instincts of every father and every
parent and I do not mark him down for
that and though there have been many
other allegations about what happened
when he was in self-isolation
and thereafter some of them palpably
false I believe that in every respect
he is acted responsibly and legally and
with integrity and with the overwhelming
aim of stopping the spread of the virus
and saving lives and I stressed this
fundamental aim because it's thanks to
this country's collective resolve in
achieving that aim that we continue to
make progress so let me give you today's
figures three million four hundred and
fifty eight thousand nine hundred and
five tests for coronavirus have now been
carried out in the UK including 110,000
401 tests carried out yesterday 259
thousand five hundred and fifty-nine
people have tested positive and that's
an increase of two thousand four hundred
nine cases since yesterday
smaller increase than we were seeing
over the last few weeks
8950 one people are in hospital with
cave at 19 in the UK down 11% from
10,000 and 85 this time last week unn
sadly of those tested positive for
corona virus across all settings 36,000
793 have now died that's an increase of
118 fatalities since yesterday and each
of those fatalities represents a family
in mourning the grief of friends and
relatives and as we mourn them we
resolve again to beat this virus and get
our country back on its feet and we can
and we will
two weeks ago I set out the government's
roadmap to begin easing the measures we
put in place to control the spread of
corona virus I said that we would do so
in a safe and controlled way based on
our assessment of progress against the
five tests we set for adjusting the
lockdown we're going to set out that
assessment in detail in the coming days
but today I can confirm that I do
believe we will be in a position to move
to step two of our plan as part of step
two we set out plans for a phased
reopening of schools because the
education of our children is crucial for
their welfare their health for their
long-term future and for social justice
and so in line with the approach being
taken in many other countries we want to
start getting our children back into the
classroom in a way that is as manageable
and as safe as possible so we said we
would begin with early years settings
and reception year one and year six in
primary schools earlier is reception
year one
and year six and today I can announce it
is our intention to go ahead with that
as planned on June the first a week on
Monday
we then intend from June the 15th for
secondary schools to provide some
contact for year 10 and year 12 students
to help them prepare for exams next year
with up to a quarter of these students
in at any point and by opening schools
to more pupils in this limited way we're
taking a deliberately cautious approach
and this comes after a constructive
period of consultation with schools
teachers and unions led by the education
secretary Gavin
Williamson I want to thank all the
teachers education childcare staff who
have stepped up to the challenge and
kept schools open throughout this crisis
the Department for Education will engage
with teaching unions local authorities
and school leaders in the coming days
giving them an opportunity to ask
questions and probe the evidence behind
our plans and the final decision will be
taken as part of the formal review into
lockdown measures which the law requires
us to undertake by Thursday we will of
course continue to consider all the
evidence as we said we would do and we
will continue to work hard with those
bodies over the course of the coming
week but I think it is important for us
to be clear about the government's
intentions now so that teachers and
parents can plan in earnest for schools
to reopen a week on Monday
no I knowledge that a June the first
opening may not be possible for all
schools but the government will continue
to support and work with the sector to
ensure that any schools experiencing
difficulties are able to open more
widely as soon as possible detailed
guidance has been published by the
Department for Education on how schools
can open in a way that is safe for
children teachers and parents while of
course we recognize that full social
distancing may not be possible
especially when teaching young children
our guidance sets out a range of
protective measures to keep children and
staff safe this includes reducing the
size of classes and keeping children in
small groups without mixing with others
staggered break and lunch times as well
as drop-offs and pickups increasing the
frequency of cleaning reducing the use
of shared items and utilizing outdoor
space all children and staff and their
families will have access to testing if
they display symptoms and this will
enables children and staff to get back
to school if they test negative and if
they test positive we will take the
appropriate reactive measures we will
continue to work with the sector to
support them to prepare for Weidner
wider opening and ensure all children
and young people can continue to receive
the best care education and training
possible we will set out what moving to
step two means for other areas such as
non-essential retail and more social
contacts over the course of the next
week so let me stress again in
conclusion we are making good progress
but that progress is conditional
provisional we must keep reducing the
incidence of this disease we must keep
that are down below 1 and that means we
must all remember the basics wash our
hands keep social distance isolate if
you have symptoms get a test we are
beating this thing but we will beat it
all the faster if we stare that control
the virus and save lives